i think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that external rewards can
actually propel us down long paths of
success and high performance they can't
it's an internal sustainable fuel source
yeah yeah i have a friend from the seal
teams and somebody asked us recently we
were given a talk and somebody said how
can i make sure that i continue to
self-reward and i'm not driven by these
external rewards how can i continue to
have that drive and uh his answer was
very good he said give away all the
external rewards you know now not
everyone can afford to do that and they
did this study where they looked at kids
they took the kids that really liked to
draw and they started giving them little
gold stars on their drawings
and then they like the gold stars for a
kid that's an extrinsic reward and then
they stopped doing that and the kids
stopped drawing they just they they
associated the good feeling of doing it
with the external rewards we have to be
very cautious about how much of our
internal dopamine we attach to external
rewards if we want to continue to grow
and pursue and focus and work hard if
you just want to get to some place and
cash in then fine
but most people find themselves in a
pretty miserable place because their
dopamine was so attached to external
rewards they need more and more of them
there's an interesting process that
occurs when people start to realize that
rewards are all internal
and what they start to do is they start
linking this duration path outcome thing
to their internal rewards the more often
that we can self-reward
some aspect of the process provided it's
in the right direction of what we're
trying to achieve the more energy we're
going to have for that the more focus
we're going to have for that and
remember that nor the reason i say
energy i don't throw that around loosely
is that
limiting amount of noradrenaline is
constantly being kept at bay you're
literally buffering the quit response
and so when people start realizing that
if they set the goals inside of the
larger goal and self-reward each one of
those they essentially have an infinite
amount of energy to pursue
those goals they have an infinite amount
of focus to pursue those goals you see
this most uh in the special operations
community and people that are selected
essentially for this process i've always
been intrigued by the selection process
the so-called buds process right because
carrying logs and
getting in cold water and all that
that's not really how
the work is that's really not what the
work is about so the selection process
is interesting because everyone shows up
fit motivated and convinced that they're
not going to quit i mean i think like
there might be a couple to show up to
show up but everybody is absolutely
convinced and then a very small subset
of them make it through the people that
make it through somehow are able to tap
into a process maybe it's
a reward process but they're able to
control something inside an environment
that is not controlled by them it's
controlled by the by the instructors and
i've always been struck by the fact that
in order to get through you just have to
not quit remember people aren't being
deselected they're not saying get out of
here you're not good enough you're not
people are deciding that for themselves
and so it's interesting because it
brings about a real world experiment of
people who are quitting and i believe
they're quitting because they can't
manage these neurotransmitters and
what's interesting is the process the
kind of unconscious genius of the buds
process is that
they've picked two sensory events
that are across the board challenging
for everybody one is cold water which is
great because
most of the time it can't kill you
right it's not like heat which can kill
you it's cold water and sleep
deprivation and so the ability to do
these like what i'm calling dpos this uh
duration path and outcome
steps and procedures
is great on when you're rested you know
uh when you're well fed well slept you
can do anything and so sleep deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because
it's very easy again rested to do all
this but so what they do is they sleep
deprived people they put them in cold
water they're trying to get them more in
touch with the way that they feel inside
than what they need to do in response to
the external demands right everyone i
know that's made it through that process
did it slightly differently but i'll
tell you how they didn't do it they
didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by
micro
slicing the day or slicing the day into
a series of meals that they just needed
to get to and then rewarding themselves
for getting to that next milestone
that's also the process i think that
allows someone to finish an ultra i've
never run an ultra but i think that
process of self-reward is
grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and i
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into these circuits are not unique to
people who run ultras or people that
make it through you know stringent
filter special operations command work
at the process of introducing thoughts
as almost like you would introduce
actions because we can introduce
thoughts and you know carol dweck has
talked about this that positive
self-talk is not the same thing as
growth mindset because positive
self-talk is almost always linked to the
ultimate outcome if i'm losing badly in
something and i tell myself i'm doing
great i know that i'm lying yes but
the idea that you can self-reward the
effort process is extremely powerful
because what it means is that if you can
recognize agitation stress and confusion
as an entry point to where you
eventually want to go
i do think that just that even just
mental recognition can allow people to
pass through it more easily like you
know running to a particular location if
you're trying to run a long distance
and then registering that as a partial
win what we know is that the dopamine
that's released in response to that
suppresses the total amount of
adrenaline and gives you more room more
time more energy to run in the running
example and this is anchored in a real
scientific result so last year there was
a paper published that essentially was
asking why any human or animal quits at
any behavior we're talking about running
or we're talking about
long bouts of work
the question is why do we quit like what
is that it turns out that
every time we exert effort a certain
amount of noradrenaline in the brain is
released and there's a sort of a counter
in the brain stem and at some point
enough no adrenaline is released and it
shuts down
cognitive control deliberate control
over the motor circuitry and we quit
that's it but the thing that can restore
those levels or it can sort of reset
those levels lower and give us more gas
more mileage is dopamine a good example
would be
if you're really slogging it out and
things are miserable just think like the
worst family vacation everything is a
disaster or a very hard physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you're almost immediately feel a sense
of relief
you see this in the team that wins the
super bowl both teams slogged it out you
have to believe they were both at max
effort the entire game look at the team
that wins they have extra energy they're
jumping all over the place so it can't
be physical energy it can't be glycogen
related it's not ketone related it's
nothing in the body in that sense it's
dopamine's ability to take that level of
norepinephrine and smack it back down
and so we can
learn this right the ability to push
through those pain points is something
that we really can export to other
aspects of life because it's the same
neurochemicals that are involved so when
you get to a particular location or
maybe you're feeling lousy you know
you're injured or you feel like you're
hurt and you can reframe it mentally and
think i'm actually still on the ladder
i'm still holding on to a wrong i know
at least that much i'm still breathing i
know that much and the lift that we get
is not some psychological pump up it's a
neurochemical thing it's dopamine
suppressing norepinephrine and saying
you're on the right path you can keep
going it's a permission to keep going